Speaker 1: Fox News melting down over the
Trump indictment. You know, we deal with
a lot of serious things on this show. And Trump's
indictment is serious because it has to do with no
one being above the law. But I would be lying if
I didn't admit that it was a delightful pleasure
to see live on our stream yesterday. Fox News
melting down. Check out this compilation from
Media Matters Cat Abu. This is just it's really
a delight. I don't know how else to say it.
Speaker 2: Democrats are branding Trump
as a criminal. It's legally pathetic.
It's clickbait. It is an unbelievable abuse of
justice. Pure balderdash. My heart is broken.
I had some tears in my eyes when.
Speaker 1: We found the guy. Folks,
we found the big, strong guy with
tears in his eyes. It's this guy,
Lou Geller Minow, a criminal defense attorney.
Speaker 2: Is broken. I had some tears in my
eyes. A little emotional. I feel the same
way. If there's a mug shot of Donald Trump,
it'll be in dorm rooms and on T-shirts.
He is an O.G.. Even if convicted,
that's not going to stop him. Donald Trump
could run in part on saying, I'm going to
pardon myself and go after the deep state.
Speaker 1: There you go, Jonathan Turley. Man,
that Turley really has hit his reputation
is just in the toilet at this point.
Speaker 2: The deep state, it's not open for a
debate that we live in a police state. It's like
Stalin's purges. We're crossing the Rubicon here.
This is a political Rubicon that has been crossed.
They have crossed the Rubicon.
Speaker 1: Basically,
it's one party haunting another.
Speaker 2: It almost feels like
they're pushing the population to react.
It is a war on conservatism and MAGA.
Speaker 1: That's Mark Levin,
by the way, screaming at the
top of his lungs there. It's really wild stuff.
Speaker 2: React. It is a war on conservatism and
MAGA. They want you to strike out. People better
be careful. And that's all I'll say about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, in terms of all of this
stuff, of the people aren't going to accept this
and blah, blah, blah, and it's people better be
careful if they are insisting that the indictment
of Trump is going to set the country ablaze and
people are going to rip it apart and civil war
and all of this stuff. The only obvious follow up
question to that is who are the individuals that
are going to do that and how do you know that they
are going to do it? Because what they are saying
is MAGA is going to do all those things. You'd
better be careful because of MAGA getting violent.
You'd better be careful because they, the MAGA
people, will rip the country apart. Now the
upside of this is so far we're closing in on 24
hours into this thing. It doesn't actually seem
like the MAGA people care enough to even go out
and protest. That's the amazing thing. And I hope
there is no violence. But for all of these clowns
saying this is going to be a really bad thing,
it's going to be uprising. You're saying the
Trumpists will be violent because the progressives
who like seeing justice, why would they go and
protest? We're just going to follow the story.
Incredible stuff that is going on.
And you really do love to see it.